the director settle an agreement we're
now looking at maybe sag doing a strike
there's many feelings about it I think
there are many issues that we need to
talk about and I think
it's hard isn't it do you put everything
in one for a potpourri of everything to
analyze and to dissect but I am scared I
I don't want AI to take over I also
believe that we live in a world where it
is active and where it will be merged
and you can't fight it it's there and it
is there to stay it is there to be
developed but maybe we can protect
ourselves with a percentage quote in
contracts maybe we don't have to sign
away and people can't and are not
allowed to use our own identity and our
voices and our movements and our faces
and expressions
same for the writers you know you can
get AI to write it will it have emotion
will it have stamina is that where we
want to go even if we can